have heard now firsthand account of a  skipper of a fishing vessel by the name  of Raymond who's told Sky News that the  first he was one of the first on scene  and the first he knew of the fact that  there were people in distress was he  heard screaming around his boat it  actually woke him up he said and some of  the extraordinary footage he shared with  us shows him and his crew pulling some  30 to 40 migrants out of the water he  said that they were from all over the  world in fact he said Afghanistan Iraq  Senegal India and they all told them  that they'd paid 5 000 pounds to a  people Smuggler in France for passage to  the UK Raymond said that these people  were all given hot or well he described  them actually as lukewarm showers on his  fishing vessel and then brought him to  land where they were then looked over by  border Force officials and given medical  assistance but all of them he said  survived